صديق انا للانسان ودود ادعى الحصان صديق
هو للانسان ودود يدعى الحصان حصان حصان
حصان انا حصان حصان حصان حصان انا
حصان وسيم وانيق واصيل
وانا ذو الذيل
الطويل وسيم وانيق
واصيل وانا ذو الذيل
الطويل لي صوت يدعى الصهيل مشهور في كل
مكان له صوت يدعى الصهيل مشهور في كل مكان
فانا حصان حصان حصان حصان انا حصان حصان ح
حصان حصان انا
حصان في جري اسرع
عدا اجري في كل
الارجا في شري اسرع
الارجاء اكل عشبا اشرب ما انا ايضا اوفى
حيوان ياكل عش من يشرب ماء هو ايضا اوفى
حيوان فانا حصان حصان حصان حصان انا حصان
حصان حصان حصان انا
[موسيقى]
حصان اتمرن دوما
اتدرب في جد الله لا
اتعب اتمرن دوما
اتدرب
في جد لا لا
اتعب اقفز اتسابق العب يعشق جميع الفرسان
يقفز يتسابق يلعب يعشقه جميع الفرسان فانا
حصان حصان حصان حصان انا حصان حصان حصان
حصان انا
حصان
i